[Music]
on this tuesday night an sos from
alberta's
icu's fears of a tsunami of covid 19
patients
they're preparing for the worst choosing
between who gets to live
and who has to die new recommendations
about vaccines and who should be
vaccinated first
plus a stern message to anyone tired of
all the restrictions
they can storm the beaches of normandy
we can sit on our couch
a reality check on ottawa's promise of
fiscal guard rails
what are the limits on pandemic spending
and
hopes for the holidays this is the first
year i will not see my parents over the
holidays the coveted compromises
canadians are making
this season
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
december is now upon us and while we all
hope the pandemic would be over by now
the reality is that in many parts of
canada the kobit 19 crisis is getting
worse
in alberta where the government was slow
to impose even moderate restrictions
case numbers are skyrocketing and the
strain on the health care system
is becoming acute hospitals are running
out of space
and staff calgary hospitals have been
told to conserve their supplies of
oxygen
this is the path alberta is on in the
span of one month
covet 19 hospitalizations have more than
tripled
as of tonight there are 479 people in
hospital with covid19 97 of them
in intensive care alberta did impose
some new restrictions last week but only
modest ones
and because of the incubation period of
the virus it will take time to see if
they had any
impact alberta is nowhere near its peak
today the province reported more than
300 new infections
and 10 more albertans died alberta now
has the most
active cases of any region in canada
more than 16
600 active infections there's fear a
tsunami of patients is coming to
hospitals where staff are already
exhausted
running out of room and facing life and
death decisions
heather urix west has our top story
tonight
inside the icu at edmonton's royal
alexandra hospital
patients are now being treated to to a
room
part of a plan to find space for more
covid patients
as the infection rate in alberta
continues to grow
we're also maximizing our occupancy by
cohorting patients
by using decommissioned spaces or
or other spaces that aren't being used
at this point in time
to prepare for the expected surge in
patients a memo sent out last friday
called for the conservation of oxygen at
calgary hospitals
due to limitation of the bulk oxygen
systems at some adult acute care sites
in calgary
and the expected increase in demand due
to the covet 19 pandemic
we need to reduce the demand the health
system is working to open another 425
beds in the coming weeks
but even those beds could fill fast
there were
24 covet patients in icu on october 30th
that number doubled in two weeks and two
weeks later it's doubled again
on tuesday alberta's opposition leaked
internal alberta health services
modeling
that shows icus could see as many as 161
patients
within two weeks time the lengths of
stay are not short so
when you have you know a lot of patients
that are knocking on the door to come
into the system
and the ones that are there aren't ready
to leave yet that's where our challenges
arise
there's nothing that can be done today
that is going to
stop new admissions for the next two
weeks
the big question is how well will the
restrictions work going forward
new restrictions were announced last
tuesday but not all measures took effect
right away
if they work new infection numbers
should start to come down within the
next week
but if they don't there could be a steep
price to pay
if they are wrong we are in a position
where we have to bring in
triage and triage tribunals
and that directly means choosing between
who gets to live and
who has to die it's a horrific
worst case scenario that becomes more
plausible by the day
heather urex west global news calgary
we know the virus is most lethal in
elderly people across canada the
majority of deaths have been
people in long-term care in bc long-term
care homes are again the centers of
outbreaks as robin gill explains that
has led to calls
for a new approach it's never
easy to put a family member in a care
home even harder
keeping them there when a covet-19
outbreak claims lives
but that's what has happened at the
delta view center in a suburb of
vancouver
leslie telford trusts the care her
mother sandy is getting there
she just doesn't trust how the virus is
being controlled within all of this we
really have to pay attention to their
quality of life
that in the will for safety we can't
lock people away indefinitely there are
57
outbreaks involving long-term care
facilities in british columbia
the second wave is forcing them to take
on desperate measures
take this senior's home in abbotsford
which cares for 700 residents
it's preparing for staff shortages by
hiring
the resident's family members to clean
today we're sitting with 14 positive
staff
and 12 positive residents so these
things
once they get into a care home they take
a life of their own the association
overseeing care facilities in bc
is led by a former provincial health
minister he's asking that
rapid tests be introduced as extra
protection we have the tests
sitting and they're available there just
seems to be some resistance on the part
of the provincial health officer and
the ministry to go forward with this but
the province doesn't think they're
accurate
and that is frustrating bc's seniors
advocate
remember that christmas is coming and
for about a quarter of the people in
long-term care
this will be their last christmas and we
have to think about
should should we not be using every tool
in the toolbox that we have available to
us
to add layers of detection and
protection if anyone should be worried
it's leslie telford this is the second
outbreak
but it has been ongoing now for almost a
month with no visitors allowed
she is one of many unable to see what's
happening inside
and the risks facing their loved ones
robin gill global news
vancouver a remote first nation in
northern manitoba is asking for military
support after an outbreak of coven 19
there
the situation is unfolding in shamatawa
first nation it's about 745 kilometers
northeast of winnipeg
according to chief eric redhead 69 cases
have been confirmed
a rapid response team is reportedly on
the ground but redhead says his
community needs more support
in a letter echoing the call for
military aid mp nikki ashton said
the acute housing crisis in shamattawa
has meant that kovit19 has spread much
faster than in other communities
and people do not have the ability to
self-isolate she said time
is of the essence we have new details
tonight about canada's plans for vaccine
rollout the prime minister says he
expects the majority of canadians to be
vaccinated by
next september but long before then
tricky decisions will have to be made
about who gets it first
the government is getting advice from an
advisory committee and it is ranked who
should get priority when the first
vaccine is approved
abigail beeman explains we have no
choice because it was the only way to
know how many doses would be
necessary dr caroline quashtan chairs
canada's national advisory committee on
immunization or nasty
a month ago nasi made preliminary
recommendations about who should get the
vaccine first
the vulnerable topped the list but it
wouldn't say who
among that group should go first
following that
we heard that the number of doses were
was even more constrained
than expected knowing canada would only
get enough vaccines for three million
people at first
quashtan tells global news nasi changed
tax
doing the math on a ranked system to
target three million canadians
in four groups people living in
long-term care facilities
and the staff taking care of them would
go first
followed by other elderly canadians
80 plus if there are enough doses the
committee recommends vaccinating older
canadians down to age 70.
healthcare workers should be vaccinated
prioritizing those on the front lines so
not those in offices but really those
who are in contact with patients
ideally those taking care of covet
patients
and the fourth group was people from
indigenous communities
nasi is still waiting on final data
about each vaccine which could change
things
some may be more effective among certain
groups and the recommendations are just
that
not binding decisions about who to
vaccinate first are up to provinces and
territories
as for how those doses are divvied up
among them that's a discussion with
ottawa
there are more conversations to come and
we will keep canadians informed as we
determine what that right order of
priority is
canada's chief medical officer of health
dr teresa tam said tuesday
after priority groups are vaccinated
targeting
everyone else by age would be the
easiest and most
scientifically sound way to protect the
population
abigail beeman global news ottawa
as we wait for those vaccines the
retired general who is now in charge of
ontario's vaccine task force
gave a pep talk to canadians who are
tired of waiting
people are tired to say oh my goodness
we can't carry on
well guess what you can't this is not
the first time in our history canadians
have
faced those incredible challenges they
can storm the beaches of normandy
we can sit on our couch stay away from
everybody else wear our masks wash your
hands not touch our
face we can do that for the next months
until we get the vaccine working through
the pandemic has been a huge test of
political leadership and a new poll
reveals how canada's premiers are faring
the angus reid institute survey found
quebec premier francois lego and bc
premier john horgan
have the highest approval rating 64
percent
new brunswick nova scotia and
saskatchewan are all next in the low 60s
approval of premier doug ford in ontario
has slipped since the first wave 55
percent of ontarians
approve of his performance now lowest in
the ranking are the two provinces with
the highest number of active cases per
capita alberta's jason kenny at 40
approval and manitoba's brian pallister
at 32 percent
the prime minister and senior cabinet
ministers are being scrutinized over
their handling of the pandemic response
too
the federal government is spending more
money than ever before to support
canadian individuals and businesses and
that will result in record levels of
debt the opposition accuses the liberals
of spending
until the cupboards are bare our ottawa
bureau chief mercedes stevenson is
looking at the finance side of things
tonight
mercedes donna nobody knows how dire the
financial situation
could become in the second wave of
covid19
with another wave of insolvencies and
job losses expected
prime minister trudeau has been clear
though his government will continue
emergency spending as long as they
believe it is needed
followed by a massive fiscal shot in the
arm of up to 100 billion dollars in
stimulus money
it's unprecedented spending so to
reassure canadians that this is not a
free-for-all
ottawa has promised guard rails that
will determine how much
and for how long the government spends
using measures like the employment rate
but there have been no benchmarks on
that and when i asked the prime minister
today
he wouldn't even give us a ballpark for
what kinds of numbers
would result in the taps being turned
off while it's not very transparent
some economists say it's likely because
the government is operating in
tremendous uncertainty
we have to wait till i think we're a
little further along till we really know
we're past this crisis before we would
expect to see anything
very substantive get us through
this deep dark hole and then get us
prepared to grow as we go through
hopefully 2021. opposition parties won't
say
if they might bring the government down
over the proposed spending
but mr trudeau is not worried about an
election this is an economic measures
that
of course will be a matter of confidence
but i am i am
reasonably confident that none of the
opposition parties
wants an election right now we certainly
don't want one with only
six sitting days left on parliament hill
any answers
will likely wait until 2021. donna
okay mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
a canadian actor with a personal
revelation
coming up the announcement from the star
of juno
in the u.s a crush of covid19 patients
is testing the healthcare system
nearly 100 000 americans are now
hospitalized with the virus
and there are warnings of a surge on top
of a surge as people who socialized over
thanksgiving
get sick at some point hospitals may
have to start turning sick people
away jackson proskow reports
with hospitals at capacity rhode island
opened 600 beds in a converted
convention center
as doctors and officials in multiple
states warned their health care systems
are nearing the breaking point
we're anticipating it there's not so
much a worry
if it's going to come there are now more
people hospitalized with covet 19 in the
u.s than at any other time
with multiple hot spots spread across
the country and a steady uptick in cases
almost everywhere else
there's only so many resources to go
around
and you know if the hospital again is
filled with cobalt patients
you know and and strain for resources
you wonder about the quality of care the
patients may get
the issue isn't just a shortage of beds
there aren't enough doctors and nurses
to go around
those on the front lines today have been
working non-stop for the past
nine months patient after patient and
changing a ppe
and worried about your own health and
your family's health and these kind of
stresses build up and over time lead to
burnout
as bad as things are the worry is about
what's to come
millions of americans defied pleas from
health officials and
traveled over thanksgiving leading to
predictions that case numbers will soon
surge even higher
this pandemic is like a high-speed train
and our projections tell us
that we are on target to derail by
around the third week of december
that's around the same time the first
doses of a vaccine will likely be
released to the public
far too late to stop what will be the
worst days of the pandemic
on tuesday the u.s centers for disease
control met to discuss who will get the
first
doses of an approved vaccine it's those
front-line health care workers
the people who've risked their own
health and safety and are about to face
their biggest test in the coming weeks
donna jackson proskow in washington
thanks
an oscar-nominated canadian actor has
come out as transgender eliot page now
uses the pronouns he they and describes
himself as transgender
in a heartfelt post on social media he
says i feel lucky to be writing this
to be here to have arrived at this place
in my life
i can't begin to express how remarkable
it feels to finally love who i am enough
to pursue my authentic self page shot to
fame after starring in the 2007 movie
juno
and later the 2010 blockbuster inception
he has been an outspoken supporter of
lgbtq plus individuals for more than 20
years
and spoke directly to them today saying
to all trans people who deal with
harassment self-loathing
abuse and the threat of violence every
day i will do everything i can to change
this world
for the better ahead the lockdown lifts
in england but leads to tears
and confusion
a giant leap for another chinese space
probe it touched down on the moon's
surface today the rover will spend the
next couple of days drilling and digging
about two kilograms of rock and dust
that will be
sent up to an orbiting vehicle and then
transported to the earth
the last time moon dust and rock was
gathered up and sent home was
a soviet mission nearly 45 years ago
now to england where a four-week
national lockdown ends tomorrow but any
relief is being tempered by the reality
a new
three-tiered system of restrictions will
replace it
as redmond shannon explains that's led
to confusion
and complaints we're sick and tired of
living in fear
we're sick and tired of being
manipulated
these protests may be the extreme end of
england's
lockdown frustration but they are
sentiments being felt to some degree
across the nation this second lockdown
has been
tough because you're just building up
your business again trying to
get back to a normal lifestyle and then
all of a sudden it's sort of taken away
on wednesday england emerges from its
four-week lockdown
a new study indicates that it has worked
somewhat
infections are down 30 percent and
continue to fall
but the sacrifices are far from over
huge sections of the country
particularly in the north will now move
to the highest of
three tiers of regional lockdowns people
are advised
not to leave tier 3 areas and bars and
restaurants there
will stay closed it has stoked the old
tensions between england's
rich south and less well-off north
how can the government justify giving
tier 1 areas the same level of business
support as tier 3
areas some mps and prime minister boris
johnson's conservative party publicly
demanded
to see the evidence behind the tiered
approach
i know that lots of people think that
they are
in the wrong tier and and i understand
people's frustration
as england loosens up slightly
neighboring whales tightens its rules
cases of coronavirus are beginning to
rise
in the over 60 age group in most parts
of wales
starting friday pubs in restaurants
across wales will not be allowed to
serve alcohol
mirroring measures in parts of scotland
the scottish first minister nicholas
sturgeon says healthcare workers
there will get an extra 860 thank you
payment
for their work in 2020. she is up for
re-election next year
and is pushing for a new independence
referendum redmond shannon global news
london
christmas in limbo next how the pandemic
is shaping holiday plans
watching global national
[Music]
it's the first day of december and
there's no doubt we're all in need of
something positive and festive to look
forward to this year
the reality is that we may not see our
friends and family this holiday season
mike charley looks at how christmas
traditions are changing
in the time of covid
in any other year you have to fight to
get a peek of this downtown toronto
christmas display
but this is what passes for a crowd in a
pandemic lockdown
[Music]
holiday awe and wonder what
how about that tree meet 2020 so it
should come as no surprise that an ipsos
pool
found that nine out of ten canadians are
modifying or
cancelling christmas altogether whether
or not they do
is another question but at least at this
stage of the game
that's what they're saying their
intention is intention
meet action it is just amazing here
in the form of toronto's gibbs family
who traded cold and lockdowns for
heat and a virtually covered free
barbados it's a once in a lifetime
opportunity this was my reasoning
when will i have the opportunity to
virtual school my kids from anywhere in
the world again i'm not sure
barbados offered long-term visas to
canadians as a way of boosting tourism
monica and her husband sam debated the
pros and cons
and decided they could do six months but
don't you miss all of this
look i miss the snow i miss this we have
snow today we have a tiny tiny tree
they also monkeys visit regularly who
chase them back into the house
every day is an adventure but even so
because of work sam is only there for
the holidays
and while they won't be alone the bulk
of their family will be in canada
so i usually host new year's eve and um
it's 30 people but my dad's birthday is
new year's day
and i usually host 30 people every year
this is the first year i will not see my
parents over the holidays
sun and beach aside she knows the
holidays won't be easy
adapting to change never is microlight
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen
there are lots of alternative ways to
spread holiday cheer
we leave you tonight with one from
vancouver
merry christmas nine bc transit buses
have been decked out with antlers and
red noses they'll be delivering toys and
cash donated by transit staff
and riders to families in need this
holiday season
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye
you